could you tell us a little bit about
your keynote lecture is going to be
about the king of
yes I think it's a kind of lecture which
is a principled way to explain to people
what is contemporary situation is well
and how is it possible to change this
situation and so we have if you want two
parts first what is the situation today
which is a crisis and so on and the
second is there some hope to go beyond
or not is there some hope you you know I
am a philosopher and I I think that the
business of a philosopher is to be
optimistic because if you are
pessimistic finally there is no use of
yourself because to be pessimistic there
is no necessity to be a philosopher the
situations suffice aside and so true to
say to two people something which can be
useful for them we must have some hope
to transform the world and to go in the
direction of a better world if it is
possible the question of possibility
finally is a material question a
political question and not completely a
philosophical question how do you see
the crisis what's wrong with the world
what what's wrong with the world but
what's the crisis
I think there is two different levels
for the kaisers there is an objective
level which is a crisis of capitalism
today the financial crisis and holes art
and I think there is also subjective
choices which is not immediately the
same thing there is something like this
organization of life this organization
of sinking an obscure vision of the
future I think this is a most important
point because for all young woman and
man is world today the future is really
obscure can we continue as now it's not
really exciting can we invent something
really different but it's not unclear
it's unclear and all the politicians all
the government's and so on are on lazy
ID to continue to continue if it is
possible but to continue or laser to
repeat if you want the situation is not
really a good future for younger men and
women of today so the Philosopher's are
also true to say ok there is a crisis
but if we cannot modify immediately the
objective eyes is because we are not so
powerful to do something like that
we can modify the subjective level of
the crisis and to propose new ideas new
vision new forms of life for humankind
tell us
what sort of new forums you're thinking
of new form of thinking yes I you know I
am supposed to say that we must define a
new form of freedom
I think freedom today is largely the
freedom to to buy some saying or the
freedom to - of money or the freedom to
do what we want when we have the money
to do and so the freedom of today is in
fact a soft of modular freedom which is
on some dependency of the situation of
the crisis and so on and so maybe we we
must search and find another definition
of freedom which is much more as a
subjective level and on the side of
creation if you want on the side of the
possibilities of mankind search and in
the field of new forms of political
organization new artistic creations new
inventions new new style of life if you
want and it's a general direction to
propose a new definition of freedom that
the formal one definition today which is
a mixture of materialism to have money
and to present achieve vision of
politics we have some governments and so
on but all that cannot define the early
freedom for today what is your advice
for young people today
I think for young people today my my
main goal is first to transmit my
experience to toast with my experience
of an old man in some sense
which I know something a really
different world before the world with
political always revolutionary IDs and
so on and first rule to transmit sort of
experience to understand clearly that
the different subjectivities can exist
today because it was not so many years
ago it was some 10 years ago 20 years
ago 30 years ago we have different
subjectivities it's a suspended
transmission after after all when we
have an experience we must ask me it's
to younger women and men and after that
to reconstruct the possibility to be
optimistic